good morning believe nation today's
message is have a dream over to you
michelle mone I wake up every morning
miss rescue TV go if I always had a
dream and my dream was to be back in
business and I always always believed
that it doesn't matter where you're from
it doesn't matter what background you
have it doesn't matter and education you
know you've got to try your best but my
situation I it wasn't for me so i left
school at fifteen with a dream and i
always always think becky you should
always think back in life never ever
think that you can't make it because
others out there are better than you
you're just as good as anyone else I
think everyone should have like dreams
or goals they aspire to have I think you
shouldn't put a limit on what you expect
to achieve so some people say like like
my dream is to have a billion dollars
but then a lot of people say like you
should make it more realistic but like
it's a dream because it's something you
can create like it could be anything
that you want and putting up I guess a
ceiling on your dreams can really hold
you back so they say like aim for the
stars if you want to get to the moon
because even if you don't reach a
billion dollars you might reach like 999
million dollars right so having a dream
is is a great for coal city I like to
think of it in terms of big wise and
little wise and and these are things
that help keep you motivated and going
your big wise but why am i doing is why
is this important what what is the big
thing I'm trying to accomplish why to
wake up every day and go do what I'm
about to do and it should be something
that's motivating and if it's not then
you gotta switch it like if you're
waking up too many days going to
something that you hate doing you're not
looking forward to it then you have to
switch and it's never going to be
perfect you're going to have days when
you feel down and out and
it's okay don't expect perfection but if
that happens for too many days in a row
then you've got to switch something up
and so I like that big why and then the
little wise for me like the day-to-day
stuff you know for you working on with
people working with people and helping
them improve when you see somebody hit a
personal hi you know that's like the
little why that's that you've helped
that one person with these big goals
that little extra daily thing that that
happens the results you're getting for
your customers I find helps me keep
motivated as well so big wise and little
minds so the question of the day today
is what is your dream so thank you guys
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and you'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso okay this race to keep me go